yes it's not it's not that bad is it I  mean you you've been there what is it a  good atmosphere in the room yeah I mean  you can drink which is fun it's like  here it's the best one to be at yes  probably the worst one to host because  they're all drunk yeah I know and then I  feel bad for everyone that has to get up  yes no one's paying anything as the  night goes on people know they've lost  yeah and then a roomful of losers yeah  you gotta calm down I have to say shut  up yeah you came over to well you do not  remember that there's no way  the researcher told me about on it in my  defense I was loads of people coming  over and it was crazy I think by  yourself and I came over  [Applause]  know anyone there so I know it was  overwhelming we were standing with the  office yeah I'm just one like first goal  of it was crazy and they loved the show  as everyone loved I didn't realize how  fat and sweaty I was until I saw the  pictures  [Music]  you